[Music]
joining us now our developer advocates
Rachel Chapman and Sarah Robinson to set
the stage for what's in store during the
developer keynote welcome Rachel please
kick us off by describing kaggle Cagle
is the home of data science so you might
know us for our supervised machine
learning competitions and we still do
that but right now we have a lot more on
the side so we've got public data sets
that anyone can use if you want to
analyze your own data you can upload it
privately you know not tear it up and we
also have a hosted jupiter development
environment so it includes GPU
acceleration offered at no charge and we
just upgraded from k 80s to p 100 so if
you're looking for a little bit of like
speed it can be a nice nice little added
bonus great and how our data scientists
and analysts utilizing kaggle to support
their machine learning projects yeah a
lot of different ways so the thing I
think that's probably most unique about
Cagle is we have a really big community
about 2.7 million registered users and
we have a super active forum so it can
be really hard to find information about
your specific questions especially
machine learning and AI and things are
moving so quickly so having a community
that you can go to and ask questions and
learn together is a really fantastic
resource and Sarah have you used cattle
in your work and seen its benefits in
the ML community yes I use Kegel almost
every day and always looking for
interesting data sets for machine
learning demos and Kaggle is my go-to
for that you can find almost any type of
data set you're looking for images text
structured data on cattle so it's been a
great tool for me what what ml a I want
to say you most excited about and tell
me a little bit about why there's some
auto now launches that I'm super excited
about really making it easy for anyone
to use machine learning without having
to have machine learning expertise so
the first I'll talk about is Auto ml
tables which makes it really easy to
build custom machine learning models on
structured data so think about anything
you might be able to put in a
spreadsheet categorical data a numerical
data building models on that with Auto
ml tables that's really easy upload your
data to the UI has to Train button and
your models ready to go another Auto ml
launch I'm super excited about is autumn
vision object detection so automail
vision can already do classification but
now what you'll be able to do is
identify regions in your image where a
certain label exists so it will return
bounding boxes so I'm super excited
about about those auto ml launches and
we're about to see a showcase
highlighting our work with the NCAA
using bigquery ml what can you tell us
about bigquery ml specifically buek UML
lets folks that have structured data
stored in bigquery a bit crazed our
cloud data analytics warehouse so it
lets you create machine learning models
on that data stored in bigquery just
with a single sequel query so you don't
have to move your data out of bigquery
to use it it's super simple to use so
you just write a query your models train
and then you can write another query to
generate a prediction I actually gave a
session on B qml earlier today with one
of our customers Triple A that's using
BQ ml to predict call volumes across
their call centers and Rachel have you
also heard about B qml on the launch -
yeah definitely and I checked out that
it's double a showcase one thing that I
found really exciting was student
developers we're working on developing
new features for analyzing basketball
games so one of them was clutch nests
like how many points you're going to
score in the last five minutes and I
thought that was super interesting
because on K go we've hosted
n-c-double-a competitions where you
predict the winning team and I think it
was a couple years ago one of the very
high placers had just use linear
regression which is available in a big
cute big query ml let me say all the
words correctly and also these custom
features that they developed so I'm
seeing some interesting synergy there
this is a perfect time to check in with
our colleague Joanna Smith who earlier
had a chance to stop by our NCAA
showcase demo
[Music]
I'm Johanna and I'm here in the industry
solutions neighborhood of our expo floor
looking at this great energy all these
people are really excited and I'm
standing with the lock who's gonna show
us the n-c-double-a demo gonna take it
away yeah so this is our second year at
Google cloud being the official cloud
provider of the n-c-double-a our theme
is know what your data knows so we've
been working with the actual NCAA Data
basketball data to make a lot of
insights and predictions so let's still
get one we just had a national title
game Virginia and Texas Tech and what
we're looking at here is the number of
possessions each team will have in
regulation
so we predicted that the number will be
63 or fewer and it was 59 in regulation
so it was right well we've done a bunch
more so one of the other things we did
was we looked at a data studio dashboard
so data studio another tool made by
Google allows you to visualize your data
yeah we have developed a bunch of
different metrics for all these teams in
n-c-double-a you can see them on the
bottom here score control clutch nest
discipline etc but we wanted to surface
that data in a way that people could use
filter and sort so this has all the 353
teams but if we just want to look at the
champion we can go here and select
champion only boom Virginia and now we
can see where they rank in all the
different categories yeah it's a good
sport for clutchless yeah so the ranks
are right there so you can tell it's
seventh out of three hundred fifty-three
teams it's pretty good a third and sport
control they they were deserving
champion so use that this is data studio
which we know is for visualization which
is really cool but have you missed on
other cloud tools I think bigquery play
the big part in this you show me how
that works
yeah so the first thing we have to do is
write make a pipeline to ingest the data
so this is a small screen here but I'll
show you this is on our Google cloud
blog we describe the entire pipeline of
how we built this data and you can see
there's a bunch of stuff and then we get
to bigquery right in the middle and I'm
a data scientist I want stuff in
bigquery because then I can go and do
all my stuff right so bigquery let's do
it and then what we do from there is we
take the data we do a lot of
manipulations and to build that metric
like spore control we have to write a
bunch of code alright so got the cloud
blog and then you also post it on medium
right yes more fun insight yeah so on
medium what we did was we wanted to talk
more in depth about how we built this
metric so one we wanted to describe in
detail for the techno people but also
talk about the basketball
so you have this thing how the final
score can lie score control right and in
here we go through a couple example
games where teams control the score
differently but then again we get back
to bigquery so here is a long query and
again it looks fairly complicated and it
kind of is but it actually is when you
think about how you go about doing
calculation bigquery makes it pretty
easy with these aggregation functions
and it runs really fast and it may be
long but it's easy to read and and it
runs really fast gets us our results for
all thousands of games in a matter of
seconds and then we can move forward and
do other stuff I love scale power now
you had one more thing in this blog
right at the bottom I thought I was
playing with your what was that an
interactive scatterplot we keep going
here eventually we get to a point where
we see this scatter plot which spots all
353 teams in their school colors and
shows their difference between the score
control and a different measure I like
it so if anyone wants to kind of find
out at home they can search and CW on
our cloud blog or they can look across
links this is the cloud GCO slash march
madness oh nice I know it's a little bit
past March but the tournament is just so
fresher than time so it should it should
be shouldn't be fun to look at well
thank you so much for talking to me Wow
amazing showcase how is bigquery ml
changing the game for machine learning
for developers and practitioners good
question two things that come to mind
for me first of all being able to work
in sequel so something we found in our
cago machine learning developers survey
is that sequel is actually the third
most commonly used language for machine
learning so and also people who are
outside of the machine learning AI space
who are just coming into it many of them
are already familiar with sequel so
being able to use tools that you already
know how to use is a really big time
saver and also you don't have to
download data locally so if you've got
sensitive data that you can't store
locally or it's just like really big and
you can't store it on disk being able to
do your question and bigquery instead of
having to like to download everything
your Python code and then upload
everything once you change your model
that can be a big time saver and to add
to that I think peak UML is a great
entry point for machine learning so you
don't have to worry about any sort of
feature engineering so if you have
categorical data for example if you're
building them all to yourself you would
have to one hotting code that
two arrays PQ ml can recognize that it's
a categorical column and transform your
data for you
democratization of data has been a big
theme at Google we really believe that
if you want innovation you have to
democratize access to data
can you talk a little about how bigquery
ml and auto ml are having an impact
towards us being able to achieve that
goal yeah definitely
so both BQ ml and auto and I'll make it
easy for anyone regardless of your
machine learning expertise to build your
own custom machine learning models so
you don't need a lot of machine learning
expertise to get started you just upload
your data choose the type of model you
want and both BQ ml and auto ml will
handle the rest and auto amel
specifically you don't need as much
later date labeled data as well so I
know the natural language API the
natural language auto mo that just
launched you only need 100 label
examples per category for each label and
your categorical Learning example which
is very little data especially when
you're looking at like a bird or Alma or
these really really enormous GPT to
enormous language models so being able
to get started with relatively little
data smaller time investment smaller
money investment for labeling is a
really big movement towards motivation
great Sarah you'll actually be talking
about the past from Cloud Auto ml to
custom model in your breakout session
can you give us a preview of the key
factors when moving from auto ml into
custom M all models yeah definitely so
the goal of our breakout session
tomorrow I'm gonna be speaking with you
thing is to teach people that may not
have built their own custom model before
how to get started because at least for
me the process of starting to learn how
to build a custom model is really
intimidating there's lots of resources
out there it's hard to know where to get
started so we're gonna break it down
talk about feature transformations
feature engineering that you need to do
to go from auto ml to custom model and
walk through some code and they'll also
be a couple live demos Rachel you'll
also be leading a session tomorrow using
Google's data and AI technologies with
cattle
what sort of things will you cover and
what part of it are you most excited
about so we are going to get people
two of kegels a lot of things have
changed recently and they're also going
to talk about several integrations that
we've made recently and honestly the one
that I'm most excited about is the
ability to take a cattle dataset and
launch it as a Sheetz instance on Google
sheets instant to be with a single click
of a button and one place where I think
this could actually be extremely useful
for people is for project management so
you're writing a kernel in a notebook
and you're you're generating let's say
your hyper parameter search space you
save that as a data set you launch it as
a sheet and then you can you assign
action items linked to other kernels you
straps use color coding which you would
want to do at a CSV but can be really
super useful for project management so
I'm very excited about that integration
Thanks
thank you so much Rachel and Sarah
thanks for having us
[Music]
you
[Music]